a group of doctors in Ireland and they  say that abortion is never necessary to  save a mother they would continue to  birth a child even if the mother was to  die I said that they say that there's  never a situation where abortion is  necessary so for example let's take  um is it preeclampsia which happens  quite later on in pregnancy or there's  some things that happen Okay so so if  something happens later in pregnancy  it's a late term abortion is very is  actually very dangerous for the woman  because she now has they have to go in  they have to rip you know the baby's  limbs apart like to crush the skull and  to and she then she has to give birth to  that um dead baby  no it's G it's it's easier to induce the  woman let her and let her give birth to  the baby this is where I'm talking late  term six months on it's easier to to for  her to give birth it'll be more  dangerous for the woman to go through a  late-term abortion than it would for her  to go through with her birth